I went to a very very strict school and
then I went they were expelled from when
- would you get expelled for never
actually said discipline that's all you
know it's kind of cool I was the
assistants expense money I've never
actually I was like spewing porno
magazines selling this before you
everything with sex with you read your
stuff guy do it like no one known you
and no one knew at all what to do with
now is it like a private school shoo
shoo private school and I tell them for
a lot of money and then what magazines
were you into oh yeah everything I mean
when I got caught for it was when I am i
glaze to go in and like take like one or
two and then said them in my bag when I
was in my school uniform on stands it's
kind of risky and then what a great
business but then at the end I got so
cocky but I would take the entire rack
and you got caught and I got caught up
in the guy what steel in the magazine so
if you got to clot distracting them and
selling I got caught stealing first of
all and then I was so cocky about it
when I remember the guy who worked in
the store shouting hey hey and my two
friends ran off pick rain I'd say around
like what I'm having I will [ __ ] up them
and the zip I hadn't zipped up my bag
and it was the day it was a post office
as well as place and this is like your
new movie you have a worst criminal
nightmare shocked how bad a criminal you
are and you were bad shitty criminal
back then yeah the video that only
though people were getting their
pensions in the post office what a
brilliant idea yeah it's all the old
people getting their pinch they're all
lining up and this guy's like pulling
all these porno magazines and it's when
ponies to have like VHS tapes like in
the plastic sheet with it he's pulling
all these things out and sitting there
like absolutely humiliated oil people
that get me disgusted
didn't hologram what he was saying he
wanted to call the cops and he's act I
did apparent to the cops and I was like
oh cool of God's collaborative and I was
trying to make up a lie of how I lived
in LA for repair chromatid service a
little bit give maybe a house like
next-door neighbor house but what a nice
guy he gave you a choice at least the
cops or your parents yeah then he went
to the school afterwards and it was kind
of a see about
days later just the whole everything
fell down like I would take basically
every single one of my friends snitch
don't mean again literally across the
board you know it's so funny if we had
only known each other back then I used
to get so much free porn I could have
supplied you if we had the nice profit
built-in